Good morning. No, it's like three o'clock
We're heading to Mount Fuji. Not really we're going to the famous pargagona.
I never remember what it's called. It looks really good, I'm excited.
It's beautiful weather and spirits are running high!
We're on this really cute train.
We're getting really close
Very exciting!
Imagine Logan Paul went on this train.
This same journey when he went to the forest.
We're on a famous train right now.
Look at all the Mount Fujis!
What happened to this one? Does anyone know?
There it is.
Salty...
Mmmm....
Woah...
Look at that slope!
Very nice.
It's about a 20 minute walk.
いきます！(Lets go!)
Oh god, there's so many steps
They're so steep.
It's gonna be worth it.
How's the view?
We can do it Marcia!
Marzia?
There's monkeys.
And boars.
These are- They look like pokemons!
Marcia Is dying.
We're almost up Marcia.
That's it!
This is it.
There it is.
Oh god.
Wow...
Amazing...
Oh yeah, we gotta take off our shoes.
We are out walking.
Looking for-
Logal paul references.
What?
Yeah he's there!
Oh, wow, it's so bright.
Show me Fuji.
We're giving him the voice,
Fuji: Hey guys, hey what's up?
So amazing...
Guys! I think there's a...
Sorry about the Logan references.
I can't help it.
We're going to a 7-Eleven...
...in the middle of nowhere.
Good night guys, good night!
おやすみなさい！(Good night)
おやすみなさい？(Good night?)
Is that how you say it?
Hello and welcome back to vlog we're standing in the...
Longest line I've ever seen in my life.
For team lab.
And it should be very exciting.
I stuck with a kid.
We got- We gotta get to shop.
Keep walking, you're blocking-
Okay, so we just went through the line and there's another line inside the line.
We're stuck here forever.
Hey, look, it's Joey. Hey, it's totally me. What a great block. Yeah. There's so much to explore
There is a Marzia, so he touched the kanji they will change citizen
What is that what did I do? Well, it's a flower Danny Joey
It's a tree house water
That's pretty dope another room what is this
Knock Jesus Christ, man
You're supposed to touch where the light is crossing come on, there's another one
How tall do they think we are?
Oh, no, damn, this is so trippy
It's not extend their look whoa with the ceiling she seems like moving on is it not
If you stare in the middle there, it's weird, this is crazy. Whoa. Oh, my mind is getting below. I'm lying. It's getting blown
Whoa, well, where am I walking? Whoa, ah don't look that don't like that
Wow Wow this is so cool
Weather whoa
So surreal looking everywhere there's something and you look down and it's just like
It's raining
Turn a token
We get such a good footage of us you can totally see everything this is an Android and Andrew has good quality, okay?
How is this whoa, oh
It's you I thought you were produce where's the stripper pole I was tadpoles
No, it's tadpoles baby I
Knew that well, well, well what a day of lights and more lights it's a trampoline well,
Enemy battle
It's black hole which how
Where's the sword let's go slide boys
Can you see me at all
Probably not. There we go. Oh
Man, I am in the middle of King nowhere. I
Decided to take a shortcut I'm blown away where it led me I'm going through this park but there's no light
I just found this little sign. Oh
my god found footage of
Pewdiepies. I'm scared that someone's gonna walk up to me. I'm like looking everywhere. It's so creepy. I'm sure this is like beautiful
Cuz there's like greenery everywhere. But man, I'm scared. I just want to make it back to the station. That's all I ask
I'm genuinely it's so cool, though. I wish you could see
This is giant tree in front of me. That goes right them
You can't see that Kenyan. No, you can't see anything cuz Android has the best cameras. There's water to the left of me
so if I take a
Wrong step I'm practically screwed basically
March says sick and
I
Decided to go out on an adventure she sent me out as well. There's like a little shrine here. Oh
I hope this black screen will do for footage for now
I'm just keeping myself company at this point. I
feel really
sad
because
We came on this trip to figure out if we wanted to live in Japan or not
and to figure out if it was possible we meet up with
Other people there's someone else
Oh god
There was another person there. He was making me your noises. I'm so scared
We made it boys. You don't why do you not see anything?
Android fix your camera. We wanted to figure out if we could live in Japan or not
So we met with visa people and we met with tax people
but it's just so
So so difficult
That we feel a little overwhelmed by it
We knew it was gonna be difficult obviously, but there's a lot of things to factor in
With not just us and the dogs and the time and the housing
It's just a big step that I don't know if you're ready to take or not. I feel like
I really want to do it though. I feel like I don't want to look back in a couple years and be like
oh, I wonder what it was like I
Wonder what it would have been like and I think I mean the unique
opportunity to do something like this and I really want to try it even though a lot of people, you know, obviously
It will be difficult
So I feel - a bit sad, I don't know because we don't know what to do. Basically I made it. I'm alive
That was insane
Never takes shortcuts ever again. I'm sure it's beautiful, but I'm not doing that again
I was scared. I'm really scared. I'm freaked out. Oh
Thank god, I'm genuinely relieved
Okay, I made it I just wanted to show that I am live I am Alive